[Musique]
culminant à 3071 m le python des neiges
est le plus haut sommet de la réunion
avec près de 55000 randonneurs par an
son refuge reste le plus fréquenté de
l'île le département propriétaire du
site a lancé des travaux
d'assaainissement des déchets qui sont à
présent terminé alors le département
nous a confié cette mission de nettoyage
et évacuation des déchets issus donc du
refuge depuis pas mal d'années et donc
on avait aussi en charge l'évacuation
d'une quinzaine de cuves qu'il a fallu
donc transférer sur le site de silaos
pour une évacuation après sur
Saint-Pierre j'espère que ça va pourter
une amélioration au niveau des
faosceptiques là déjà tout c'est ass
enlevé c'est déjà plus beau il y avait
trop de CIT qui déposaient autour du git
donc il fallait les enlever le
Département souhaite valoriser ce refuge
pour cela d'autres travaux de
réhabilitation
prév pour les prochaines années la deè
pH ce sera en fait des travaux
conservatoires sur le J existant et la
dernière grosse opération qui sera menée
sera une reconstruction dans dans 5 7
ans du JIT actuel pour donner en fait un
meilleur confort à la fois au jitur au
randonneur et donner une meilleure
vision de de l'île notamment dans ces
montagnes le Département souhaite faire
du git du python des neiges un
hébergement de qualité au cœur du
patrimoine naturel de la Réunion
[Musique]